my boyfriend's new tattoo makes me feel
like a pedophile whoa you're riding a
dick looking at a child's face no way
it's honestly ruining our sex lives I
doubt I would ever be able to have sex
can you put a t-shirt on or something
yeah this is where I [ __ ] up I
shouldn't have said this but I don't
handle conversation well and I pretty
much lost my cool at this point and I
told me I told him to go jack off to a
picture of his brother and tell me how
that makes him feel oh my God she went
like red level like she went oh my God
that wasn't necessary I wouldn't have
said that um he's then started shouting
that if it was seriously that big of a
deal for me then he would get the whole
thing lasered off but he looks like
basically killing his brother all over
again oh my God okay calm down these
people are [ __ ] going way too far
with each other what is happening right
now
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of big
mood we're glad you're here it's me Gina
and I'm here with the beautiful Jess
from Texas that left us and abandoned us
here in the [ __ ] heat actually
that's true and we have Tiff and of
course our guest here yep jokes that I
like outside right now he's looking like
this oh cute he thinks I like cats I
don't know why he thinks that because I
[ __ ] hate cats and they usually go to
the ones that they know hate cats yeah
they're trying to make you love him
earlier he wasn't fighting I don't hate
cats but I'm not like I looked over he
had his mouth hanging open tongue out
and he drooled yeah I was like what the
[ __ ] was that and I googled it they're
like cats do that when they're really
happy and relaxed I'm like oh thank you
[ __ ] weirdo why are you so happy
happy I have friends here uh so today uh
we're talking about relationship advice
uh there's a subreddit called
relationship advice where people post
you know their problems whatever and
people give them advice and I pulled a
bunch of um posts from there and I
wanted to go through them with you guys
I'm going into blind also I just read
the title I don't know what the story is
and we're gonna sit here and give some
advice because some of these are [ __ ]
wild and it's not necessarily just like
romantic relationships but like
friendships and family too so I pulled
up a bunch because we're the most
qualified together super qualified we're
just reacting to them maybe right
reacting to people's messed up
relationships all right the first one is
my boyfriend's new tattoo makes me feel
like a pedophile whoa
I don't really know how to begin this
I'm just going to Dive Right In we've
been together for four years now living
together for two and he's planning to
propose last year however his younger
brother who was only six years old
passed away this took a major toll on my
boyfriend obviously but especially
because he was extremely close to his
little brother
the problem arised a few months ago when
my boyfriend mentioned he wants to get a
tattoo to commemorate his little brother
and ask what my thoughts were on this
idea he has no other tattoos and never
expressed wanting one before but I was
completely supportive we didn't really
talk about it again until he told me he
had booked a time with the tattoo artist
it was on a day I was working so I
couldn't go with him I was really
looking forward to seeing it thinking it
was going to be something small and cute
I did not expect him to come back with
an almost life-size headshot of his
brother slap across the majority of his
[ __ ] chest oh my God whoa
it was definitely a shock but I reacted
positively and told him it looked really
good oh honey that's great
it was only the outlines and such at
this point and or oh it was only the
outlines and such at this point he said
he was going back to get it all filled
in it's been a few sessions now and he's
had a whole shebang done colors shading
everything to a point where it could be
mistaken for a photo now oh good tattoo
artist
I can't deny that it's a seriously
incredible piece of artwork
um and it's it's a boyfriend is really
proud of it my only issue with it is
she's writing him during sex I knew it
it takes up such a large space on his
chest and it's the only tattoo he's got
it doesn't help that he's pretty pale
and doesn't have much hair so the tattoo
really stands out and my attention is
constantly drawn to it not to mention
this is like the Mona [ __ ] Lisa any
position we're facing each other I
always end up making eye contact with it
and every time I do it makes me feel so
uncomfortable and absolutely kills the
mood you're writing a dick looking at a
child's face
[Music]
it's honestly ruining our sex lives I
doubt I would ever be able to have sex
can you put a t-shirt on or something
yeah
I haven't told my boyfriend any of this
I feel like I can't say anything
negative about the tattoo sorry no not
right now yeah
um lately we've mainly been having sex
positions where I'm facing down away
from him she's like oh let's do the
doggy style yeah this feels better yeah
she's staring at the wall instead oh
okay damn I'm not sure what to do should
I talk to him am I overreacting is our
sex life officially dead no I mean
you're planning on marrying this guy you
most definitely have to talk about it
yeah get my water personally my first
reaction was to think that like when
something really major happens in your
life
you shouldn't react to it with something
super major until time has gone by so
like the death of the brother I feel
like a year or two should have gone by
before how long is it a permanent tattoo
was made
last year so yeah I don't know maybe
more time should have gone by I don't
know but like never make such a huge
reaction to something when you're
emotional I think like a very permanent
large decision because you're just so
emotional and you're not really thinking
straight and like I'm sure the brother
wouldn't necessarily if he kind of grew
up to be a man and never passed away
would necessarily want his brother to
just have a picture of him like all
across his chest like that like he might
have been like bro I love you but that
was a bit much you know what I mean like
you were just you were in your feels I
appreciate it but that was a lot you
didn't necessarily have to to go that
far with this tattoo but now the
Tattoo's there yeah now what now I feel
like she's gonna have to tell him but
maybe wait even longer like there needs
to be like he needs to settle in with
his own tattoo maybe eventually he'll
start to regret it a little bit so when
she says it it won't be so bad if you do
doggy style for a little bit you know I
remember talking to my dad about wanting
to get a big tattoo
um he's like okay but whatever you do
don't get like a Buddha because you know
my family's like Buddhist yeah I was
like why he goes because when you're
having sex someone would be looking
right at a Buddha I was like okay first
of all don't talk to me about sex all
right that's gross and second of all my
gosh [ __ ] you're right that's true yeah
like putting something super like
sentimental or like that means a lot on
your body I feel like is kind of a weird
Choice yeah like especially the an image
of something else I do I do have all my
tattoos are sentimental well no I mean
like something that like like a
religious figure like you yeah you just
put on your body and it's like you're
over here [ __ ] sinning you know like
yeah people that have uh portraits of
Jesus and the cross all over their
bedroom and like they're having sex in
there and doing some dirty [ __ ] yeah
like maybe it should be saved for like
it's a little weird it is true a hallway
or like somewhere where like less
disgusting things are happening yeah
unless they don't have sex maybe they
don't have sex but so what I would
probably do in this situation is just
bite the bullet take on my own excuse
for wanting to keep the lights out
honey I feel fat can we turn the lights
off so sex in the dark is the only
[ __ ] really that's the only solution
I would even though it's fresh
maybe I'm that's probably wrong
I'm probably wrong but I'm gonna say
something and the most gentle way I can
and suggest a shirt yeah and tell him
why though yeah then he's gonna be like
I have to wear a shirt for the rest of
my life no no you don't oh yeah when we
have sex yeah I mean you made that
decision or you can make it really like
not because you feel like a [ __ ]
gross pedophile you know of course it's
so weird but how about like can you wear
a shirt because I don't want to see a
tattoo because it makes me it brings me
out of the mood because I it reminds me
how sad you are
no I'm sorry it's a child yeah because
I'm sad because you I get reminded that
your brother reminded and then that you
know it makes me sad that you're sad
like you know you're not seeing your own
chest all the time yeah I have to see it
yeah so there's updates I'm just not
right away I mean you got to give it
some room I don't know girl if I'm
trying to have sex
I'm gonna bring it up no you gotta put
some space in there so there's an update
um he noticed that she was acting a
little bit different now
um and then so she said
I told him I absolutely love it for what
it is and what it stands for but it's
difficult for me to say in a moment
because it's really hard not to look at
it and be reminded of what happened I
stopped here to see his reaction
and then he said so what you want me to
get rid of it or get rid of him I
explicitly said no I would never ask you
to do that and then told him it might
just take me some time to get used to it
until it's not so noticeable anymore and
in the meantime maybe we should keep his
shirt on during sex all right how about
that just turn off the lights uh this is
where [ __ ] starts I hit the fan oh yeah
I told you you gotta put some [ __ ]
space in there it could be wrong yeah
he said all that sounded ridiculous to
him and that I was being extremely
insensitive and selfish and quote
honestly sick for even associating his
little brother with sex and asked if I
was [ __ ] sick in the head oh come on
no let's see he's emotional right now
you can't [ __ ] be pushing that you
can't be poking the bear she says okay
now this is where he noticed he noticed
she was like behaving differently how do
you address that I would just be like I
I don't know what you're talking about
I'm on my [ __ ] period but can we turn
the lights off now sorry sorry I dropped
my phone on you I'm so sorry Kitty
Katina dropped her phone on the cat and
the cat freaked out you think you're
wearing jeans yeah good thing I was
wearing jeans he would have like
scratched the [ __ ] out of me I'm sorry I
mean he got a little Pokey but it's not
like I heard that yeah I'm sorry I got a
little pokes lay back down I'm sorry
he's like no [ __ ] you dude here yeah
stop
geez Kitty what is your problem he got
freaked out again for no reason
almost catch up
oh my God
you're good
you're so cute did you get your boobies
oh God that's [ __ ] hilarious Don't
force a cat to sit somewhere if he
doesn't want to yeah Jess is already
like I don't [ __ ] like cash she lies
she's been petting him
she goes
Bad Kitty can't wait to watch that
footage later I know oh gee now he's
[ __ ] licking his own dick yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was hilarious okay
so she goes on to say this is where I
[ __ ] up I shouldn't have said this but
I don't handle conversation well and I
pretty much lost my cool at this point
and I told me I told her I told him to
go jack off to a picture of his brother
and tell me how that makes him feel oh
my God she went like red level like she
went oh my God that was unnecessary I
wouldn't have said that oh my God no
matter how mad oh my God he completely
exploded at this point saying that it
was a disgusting thing to say which I
agree and started calling me a number of
names he then started to get extremely
personal saying I never cared about his
little brother and that I'm probably
happy he's out of the picture going on
Jesus oh they should not get me they
should yeah they needed a lot of
counseling they should not get married
right now
um he's then starts shouting that if it
was seriously that big of a deal for me
then he would get the whole thing
lasered off but he looks like I'm
basically killing his brother all over
again oh my God okay calm down these
people are [ __ ] going way too far
with each other what is happening right
now oh my God that's zero to one
thousand
then this [ __ ] morning I get a lovely
[ __ ] call from my boyfriend's sister
who called me disgusting and heartless
and evil apparently he's been going
around to the family and telling all of
our friends telling them I've given him
an ultimatum yeah you can't get married
right now Jesus why is he lying and
exaggerating oh my God they cannot get
married right now what the [ __ ] I
explicitly told him I would never ask
him to do that when I told his sister
this she just called me a liar and a
[ __ ] [ __ ] wishing all my siblings
were dead and then hung up
now the sister's [ __ ] psycho oh my
God okay damn bad news bearers they need
to get the they need a break yes they
need to take a break come crazy damn
wild Updates this is crazy so another
update
um blah blah blah blah it's been a crazy
week we spent the he and I spent the
whole night talking where he revealed
he's been using a lot of drugs recently
and drinking a lot more to deal with his
grief he told me he feels responsible
for his brother's death because while I
was pushing for us to file for custody
he was on the fence a blah blah whatever
um long story what happened they wanted
to get because she wanted to go okay
um he told me he feels responsible for
his brother's death because while I was
pushing for us to fall for custody he
was on the fence about the idea and now
he feels his brother would be alive if
we had filed for custody over him first
when I first suggested it he said
because of this he's been developing a
lot of feelings I'm not sure how the kid
actually died oh damn but okay so it's a
complicated yeah so
um long story short there's a little
tldr here saying we both apologize for
what we said In the Heat of the Moment
boyfriend revealed he regrets getting
the tattoo and it was a sister who
convinced him to get it in hopes it
would break us up
hold on oh so that's why the sister okay
so wow like it's such a [ __ ] soap
opera yes I know holy [ __ ]
ever we talked about the argument he had
with his sister up until now I was under
the impression that my boyfriend went on
his own to get the tattoo done but it
turns out his sister went with him to
his first session and it was her who
convinced him to get it on his chess
whereas my boyfriend originally wanted
it to get a drawing of his brother's
favorite stuffed animal not only this
but I guess the brother and the sister
had an argument it came out that his
sister wanted him to get such a drastic
tattoo because she was hoping it would
cause a rift between us Tiff give us
like something in Spanish right now like
we need like a what is this [ __ ] what
are we calling her right now what are we
calling her what are we calling her yeah
apparently
oh yes
scandalous
apparently she felt like I was tearing
their family apart by trying to file for
custody and she doesn't want me dating
her brother anymore if that sounds
totally ridiculous to you it's because
it is yeah
um I feel like they're trying to help
um worse uh we'll see my boyfriend
didn't go around to all our friends that
was her sister lying she was the only
one he told and he promised to set the
story straight for my family members uh
that she's mentioned it to we've both
apologized to each other we're getting
in contact with a grief counselor so
tldr boyfriend's breath yeah oh my God
and then we're seeking grief counseling
and considering getting more tattoos to
make the current one less noticeable
no maybe not that one just stop with the
tattoos this is going crazy that
sister's a [ __ ] that's crazy that was a
Twist I did not see right oh my God why
is the sister over here saying that she
that the girlfriend's trying to like
cause a rift in the family like
where is she in trying to get custody of
the little brother where the [ __ ] are
the parents like what's happening I need
to know more details okay okay it's
because I skipped a bunch because I
didn't want to make it too long this is
just okay okay the reason I guess we
don't know the reason why he died but um
apparently my boyfriend's parents are
major screw-ups to put it bluntly and as
a result his little brother spent a lot
of time living with us to the point
where he practically called or we
practically became like a mom and dad to
him and even discussed filing for
custody so we don't know how he died but
yeah maybe the sister was just like
taking the parent like she's probably
[ __ ] up too yeah you know yeah there's
a lot of toxic side taking you know well
if she has the brain capacity to come up
with this where it's like let me
convince my brother to get this big ass
tattoo of our dead little brother across
his chest so then this [ __ ] could be
out of our lives like what the [ __ ] kind
of [ __ ] oh my gosh definitely don't
let the Boy live with her she's
conniving and manipulative and crazy
she's insane psycho oh my God that was
crazy that was juicy and crazy yeah I
love judging other people's lives yeah
I'm like wow I'm so glad I don't have
any like crazy [ __ ] going on in my life
right now because wow that sounds like
it's not reality right that's heavy wow
that's heavy real wow that would make a
pretty good like episode of a show
anyways I would say cut off the sister
also [ __ ] that
um and yeah I'm glad they're getting
grief counseling and walking around the
tattoo I don't know that they have to
cut off the sister but if the sister
like if all this is out now and then you
know she's not willing to be like sorry
like I just didn't like you blah blah
blah but like whatever we'll work on it
like then maybe they could not cut her
out like because she could never be
trusted again never be trusted I mean
all she did was like push him to get a
tattoo and lie to everyone like she's
just saying she could be going through a
lot too all I'm saying is let's give the
sister a chance to be better and if
she's not then fine let them have a
yeah it's crazy
um
let me see hold on hold on hold on hold
on another update let me see if I can
find out how that argument came up with
the brother and sister my boyfriend
spent two nights at his sisters and
during this time I decided to send them
a link to my Reddit post instead of
writing him a letter I felt like
everything I needed to say was in those
two threads his sister read through them
too and that started a massive argument
between them that revealed some shocking
information there you go there you go so
like she basically told her side of the
story on Reddit and then the brother
read that it was like wait a minute yeah
I didn't tell you yeah and then it kind
of started unraveling yeah I mean
communication obviously is key and
people are not communicating more right
situation oh my god oh geez that was a
lot that was a lot I feel like I need a
cigarette that was great Jesus Christ
that was crazy but the solution to
tattoo is kind of weird
like let me add more tattoos so this
giant of a child is not noticeable what
else are you gonna put around that put a
Batman mask on him
we're making like those wrappers with a
whole bunch of tiny tattoos on the kid
give you a little beard oh God okay
sorry we're talking about no laser laser
would be better yeah for sure there's no
way especially how she described it
there's no way that they can cover it or
make it less significant maybe we need
to laser that it can be hard to fit
everything in especially when it comes
to luggage with base there's room for
everything even if you're an over Packer
15 pairs of underwear for a three-day
weekend trip no problem a couple extra
pairs of pants bring it all with base I
have to say that they sent us some
luggage I've got the carry-on roller
luggage and I've got the Weekender bag I
love them they look great I've actually
seen some other people at the airport
using them and I'm like hey you know
what's up and another thing guys you
guys don't know this because it hasn't
been released in an episode but I have a
new boyfriend and he lives 45 minutes
away from me so I am using this
Weekender bag every single weekend when
I go see him and I love it I love the um
hard bottom that's like separates you
could put shoes and stuff in there and
then you can put your clothes and stuff
on the top it's great go check out the
Weekender back base was created by
actress Shea Mitchell to make sleek and
affordable bags luggage and accessories
designed to help you travel effortlessly
while still looking fashionable right
now base is offering our listeners 15
off your first purchase by visiting
basetravel.com big mood go to
basetravel.com big mood for 15 off your
first purchase that's
b-e-i-s travel.com big mood the holidays
can create even more waste than usual
each year Americans throw away 25 more
trash from Thanksgiving to New Year's
what if we told you that there is a way
to get all your holiday shopping done
without the guilty feeling over the ways
that typically comes with it meet blue
land the holidays are upon us food
friends family and cleaning our loved
ones can be a bit messy and warm mess
equals more waste but not with blue land
blue land is on a mission to eliminate
single-use plastic by Reinventing
cleaning Essentials to be better for you
and the planet and this holiday season
blue land is having its best sale of the
year so you can save up and shop
sustainably for your friends family and
even yourself the idea is simple grab
one of the beautiful forever bottles
that we have fill it with warm water
drop in the tablet and get cleaning
refills start at two dollars and you
don't have to buy a new plastic bottle
every time you run out you can even set
up a subscription or buy in bulk so you
never run out of products that you use
the most from cleaning sprays to hand
soaps to toilet cleaner and laundry
tablets all blue land products are made
with ingredients you can feel good about
try their clean Essentials kit which has
everything you need to get started in
signature scents such as Iris Agave
fresh lemon and Eucalyptus mint Plus for
a limited time blue lands hand soap is
getting a festive upgrade with a
beautiful chocolate box inspired gift
set with cozy scents like Evergreen
Winterberry and peppermint I love using
this because I feel like it saves up so
much space in my cleaning drawer with
all the products in there all I need is
just little tablets and it's actually a
really cool idea to take advantage of
their best sale they year go to
blueland.com big mood you won't want to
miss this blueland.com big mood once
again that's blueland.com big moon okay
the next one is I 24 year old male I am
worried that my sister has feelings from
my girlfriend oh juicy
my girlfriend and I have been together
for two and a half years and we have a
really great relationship my sister and
I have always been close I was really
happy when she and my girlfriend met and
hit it off right away they get along
insanely well and it's awesome or it was
awesome it might be important to point
out that they are also both bisexual oh
everything was normal up until about
three months ago they started hanging
out together more often than usual uh
taking day trips and having sleepovers
and going for dinners that's weird I
didn't care about it initially a
sleepover with my boyfriend's sister
[Music]
um he's 24 sister's 26 girlfriend is 24.
that's just weird I mean like we've done
like girls trips yeah but I'm not dating
your brother
I've I've seen when when they become
better they're like trying to be friends
like sisters we just like the context of
the bisexual [ __ ] but without it let's
rewind it just to me the sleepover thing
is kind of like why like poor why maybe
it's because we don't really do
sleepovers and it's weird for us I feel
like when I was younger though like I
would have like friends come stay the
night sure yeah for sure but like I
don't know my boyfriend's sister who's
also a bisexual like that's just well
that's what we're hearing so far but
maybe it's it's skewing our let's hear
let's hear the rest of it okay because I
don't know before disaster at first if
we take out the bisexual context it just
sounds like they're trying to like
become family like they're trying to get
closer as family I'm fine with all of
that it's the sleepover thing that just
weirds me out so I didn't care about it
initially I thought it was cool that the
two most important women in my life were
such good friends then my sister let's
call her Amy then my sister Amy started
making comments saying that if we ever
broke up she's first in line to date my
girlfriend Emily okay she calls Emily
her wifey and follows follows her around
like a lost puppy Amy says that Emily is
our girlfriend and I swear she gets
jealous when I interact with her then
last week I got home from work and as I
walked through the door I can hear them
chatting in the living room this isn't
out of the ordinary
it was what I heard that really bothered
me my sister said holy [ __ ] I have such
a crush on you in the most lustful voice
I've ever heard wow Emily laughed and
their conversation moved on but it
really didn't sit well with me so later
on I asked Emily what they were talking
about I think context is important she
told me that they were shopping early in
the day and were doing a little fashion
show for each other she said that those
kinds of comments are normal between
girlfriends and it's nothing to worry
about it makes sense to me and I trust
Emily I mean I make those comments too
to my lesbian friends but I'm like so
painfully straight
but I understand like oh my god [ __ ]
you're so hot it's like I just want to
pop your titty in my mouth right now you
know I could see how it could be a joke
yeah I can say it as a joke but in the
lustful like I have something also he's
a guy so he's probably like he doesn't
understand true he might have
exaggerated he's like putting it through
his porn brain and then yeah or like how
I talk like two Nikki blades yeah you
would assume that she was seriously
trying to [ __ ] Nikki blades if you
really like if you were if you don't
have a special context yeah I decided to
talk to Amy my sister I asked how their
shopping spree went and then gently ask
her what the crush comment was about she
got very defensive and accused me being
jealous of her relationship with enemy
with Emily
then told me the girl to [ __ ] up I'm not
worried about Emily doing anything
behind my back to betray me there's just
something about the way my sister is
acting that irks me
hmm do you guys want to do you think do
you think that the brother is is
harboring a little bit of homophobia
you think potentially I don't think so
you don't think so because this I feel
like if she's like grow the [ __ ] up I'm
[ __ ] around I'm making friends with
your girlfriend and joking around and
he's just like so worried about his by
his sister insecure yeah I don't know
like maybe I don't know maybe he doesn't
understand how they work or yeah he's
probably feeling insecure
because of his sister and also because
of his own girlfriend being bisexual
yeah like the bisexual nature like I
could take your girl if I wanted to
right like he's like well what what's
going on here yeah what's happening yeah
I feel like yeah that's that's valid but
also I do find it kind of like just
weird
I want to know if you're doing too much
yeah I want to know what the girlfriend
says about all this because he's like
yeah I'm not worried about my girlfriend
at all whatever okay well then talk to
her it seems like a lot of it the it's
Amy flirting and not the girlfriend and
she's just kind of like yeah like that
would be nice so there's an update okay
there have been some developments when I
got home from work yesterday even
yesterday evening I saw them on the
couch watching a movie so I decided we
should just get it over with and talk
about this okay I basically just asked
him if there's anything going on between
them mentioned how much extra time
they've been spending together it's like
they're dating my sister immediately
started sobbing an enemy
why do you keep saying enemy for Emily
weird because she's the enemy right
that's the girlfriend I know and Emily
just looked really sad Amy couldn't
speak through her tears so Emily filled
me and turns out Amy has been going
through a really bad breakup and not
taking it well Amy's boyfriend cheated
on her with multiple women and gave her
an STD oh [ __ ] is it read oh your ex oh
I heard you say oh she doesn't read all
it says that is it did you date retroy
also yeah yeah um we've all dated retort
we're at some point because he's out
there he's amongst us
um I guess it ended in a big blowout and
he trashed her place and threw her
around no three months ago Emily noticed
that something was wrong and asked her
what was up while they were out for
lunch and Amy couldn't hold back and
spilled all of it and then that's when
Amy started staying or Emily that's when
Emily started staying over the place for
a few reasons to help her fix up her
home support blah blah blah and then Amy
found out that she's pregnant oh this
guy's baby he's over here all worried
about this bike yeah and it's some dude
causing [ __ ] Problems oh my God
that's what I'm saying it's gonna be an
uncleized homophobia a little bit in
there they're extra Hangouts were mostly
to do with preparing for their new baby
pregnancy including the fashion show
which was maternity wear for both of
them
what I was perceiving as jealousy from
Amy was actually a long longing Envy of
a solid relationship that Emily and I
have yeah
um The Crush Comet and wife nicknames
were literally just girly comments it
was
um Amy was reacted to my question
because she was so deeply betrayed by
this guy and being accused of doing that
was very hurtful yeah I didn't even know
Amy was dating anyone seems like I am
the [ __ ] yeah he is the [ __ ] you
should be on am I the [ __ ] yeah top
comments saying you have no reason to
blame yourself she didn't tell you she
had a boyfriend yeah yeah he had no idea
anything was happening all these plot
twists man yeah that was great
[ __ ] that was hella juicy yeah it just
goes to show like it's so easy for us to
like our insecurities to take over and
to like create an entire [ __ ] story
like he just created this whole
storyline in his head through his little
porn brain that his bi-sister and his
bi-girlfriend were [ __ ] behind his
back
when in reality her sister just got out
of an abusive relationship and is
pregnant with an abuser's baby her
apartment was all [ __ ] up and his
girlfriend was like saving
her like trying to help her
why didn't the girlfriend tell I know
like you know your sister's going
through stuff yeah maybe she was like I
just don't tell him like it's
embarrassing I don't have to tell my
boyfriend what he's got a dad he will
dig yeah my sisters what the [ __ ] who's
[ __ ] with my sister you know what I
mean he's gonna start digging no I
wouldn't even say that it would be like
he broke up that's all she's going
through things yeah period yeah you
don't need to know more than that yeah
she's going through stuff and I'm
helping her out yeah period
I'm annoyed that he didn't even talk to
his girlfriend about it though yeah
that's the part that it irks me the most
where it's like you're having issues
with this relationship that your
girlfriend has with your sister
clearly you should speak to one of them
first he did talk to his own sister and
she was like whatever brush it off but
he's suspicious sister he was accusatory
of her when he brought it up too yeah so
he's accusing the sister then go to the
girlfriend and ask like hey is anything
going on like do you feel like my
sister's coming on to you and then the
girlfriend could be like oh she's just
going through stuff period yeah Chase
could have been avoided with some
communication these are crazy well
they're younger too they're like young
mid-20s have you guys ever had to deal
with someone that you that was in your
circle that knew that you can kind of
tell they had a crush on your
significant other a crush on my
significant other no I don't date um
desirable men
that's funny
all right
a crush on my significant other oh
that's interesting
um not like someone that I knew in real
life but there was a lot of fans that
always liked Casey and they'd be like oh
my God he's so hot and I'm like girl I
know
um the next one is
my wife she's 33 years old my wife is
denying we're married and wants to be
called my
girlfriends were married my wife I don't
know if it matters but my wife 33 female
and I 29 male
have been married four years now coming
on five we have generally had a good
relationship and a good marriage why are
you guys shocked because they've been
married for four years so long
okay what the [ __ ] and he's younger than
her too so maybe it's an insecurity yeah
I think
um we had a she's cheating
oh yeah let's get the guesses out of the
way she's cheating she's cheating she's
embarrassed about something uh she was
working with younger people and feels
old that she's married we should do this
from now on every title I read we just
make assumptions and see how wrong or
right we are why would you not want to
be butt itches
you literally just scratch your butthole
right in front of me my butthole and her
and her ears
I so my guess is gonna be
that
she's genuinely embarrassed by their
relationship in general and like doesn't
really love him and she's like in the
[ __ ] relationship for some other
reason because like being married to
someone is kind of being claimed yeah so
she's just like doesn't want anyone to
really know that she's claimed by him so
it's like she doesn't really love him
for some reason she's definitely hiding
it from someone that's my assumption
okay
um we had a reasonably expensive wedding
which we're still paying for now I have
another example
she
okay that kind of goes with the cheating
one never mind but I was gonna say that
um like she's trying to somehow get
married or she was married or something
somehow like like something yeah
something's legal okay we had a
reasonably expensive wedding which we're
still paying for now I get the bill
every month to prove it uh yeah uh my
wife took charge of planning the wedding
so it was to her taste she seemed to
enjoy it at the time and for the first
few years of our marriage she would look
back at the wedding with me and happily
or with me happily and without issues in
recent months I've noticed my wife's
attitude to a our wedding and B our
marriage itself shift it began by her I
thought jokingly at the time referring
to herself as my girlfriend she told me
to buy her a girlfriend card for
Valentine's Day rather than a wife one
for example card I have a new guess this
is a kink and she like wants to play
like their new like their new and newer
relationship again and like she misses
the old the beginning of the
relationship when it was good and now
it's funny fail and it sucks it's like
uh it's like let's be strangers again
okay I
was playing around at first but this
Behavior has only escalated two months
ago my wife stopped wearing her wedding
ring no I was understandably upset and
asked her if there was something wrong
she told me everything was fine and she
just doesn't want this like the
sensation of jewelry on her hands all of
a sudden after four years my wife has
never really liked rings and jewelry so
this could be the case but I'm like that
when we are with friends my wife will
get upset if I talk about her as my wife
rather than just a girlfriend she will
go as far as to interrupt me when I'm
telling a story to correct me on our
relationship initially this was
something our friends laughed at but now
everyone just finds it understandably
awkward yeah yeah super weird doing it
with the people that already know that
they're married yeah they're just
delusional you just started referring to
Casey as your boyfriend I would think
you lost your [ __ ] mind another uh
assumption she has amnesia
um one of our friends was talking about
their own wedding which is scheduled for
early next year they asked for advice
from my wife about how she planned hers
my wife responded with what wedding
what the [ __ ] yeah oh something's wrong
with this girl when our friend continued
talking about the table decorations my
wife had used my wife visibly teared up
in front of the whole group and had to
step outside
later that evening I asked her directly
if she has a problem with our
relationship brain tumor or if I'm doing
something wrong in our marriage she
assured me that everything is fine
between us from my perspective outside
this issue our relationship is as strong
as ever we are considering kids in the
near future our sex life is great and my
wife recently suggested that we even get
matching tattoos as a renewal of our
love no don't do the tattoo thing is
there any advice anyone can offer what
what the [ __ ] I just don't get it okay a
therapist needs to weigh in on this yeah
I am so good she needs to be about alert
like a puzzle like no updates you [ __ ]
what are the comments uh the top comment
says no kids until you find out what the
hell is going on and no matching tattoos
no no what the [ __ ] there's no update I
I feel cucked right now
uh second comment says sounds like a
mental breakdown go see a doctor over
there yeah this woman really needs some
help seems like she might not know
weird
um this is gonna be an unsolved mystery
that is going to bother me it's gonna
bother me yeah why does someone want to
be a wife why does she want to ignore
the fact that she had a wedding to
people that were at the wedding
so these comments are saying honestly it
sounds like a severe mental health
crisis a neurological issue early onset
yeah Alzheimer's mean yeah something's
happening something that sounds like she
has Amnesia or something yeah brain
tumor this happened to a friend of mine
he started losing parts of his memories
he had a tumor the size of a kiwi they
had to remove God damn uh if she got
upset when friends talked about her
table decorations it sounds like his
wife genuinely believes they are not
married as per other comments meds or
health issues go to a doctor
I know two people who acted weird and
did really crazy and dangerous things
totally out of character because they're
meant to mess up their calcium levels go
to a doctor
um wow yeah everyone's just saying go to
a doctor yeah this is crazy I think so
that's the only thing that is absolutely
insane yeah Mental Health crisis yeah
maybe she has like early Alzheimer's
that's 33 or a brain tumor wow you guys
are [ __ ] up just thinking she's
cheating and [ __ ] how dare you know we
were guessing before all the details
came out which is why that is a
dangerous game that's what a dangerous
game to play I wonder no matter what you
get to judge everyone that's true
not judging someone maybe that's okay
that makes sense that when her parent or
when her friends ask about the marriage
she's like what marriage yeah oh that's
scary but it's weird that privately
though when he addresses it with her
she's like no we're good honey yeah
that's weird that is weird I wonder if
he's literally saying though like why
are you acting like we're not married in
front of everyone we've been married for
four years yeah and because how do you
get around that yeah well he said he
asked her is everything okay she's like
yeah yeah so he's probably not yeah not
being directed enough next one says my
girlfriend said something to me
yesterday that I felt like a punch to
the gut
my uh we're both 17 and my girlfriend
and I have been going out for about a
little bit over eight months we didn't
have sex together straight away and
first did it only a few weeks of weeks
ago I was a virgin after how many months
eight months eight months oh okay so
they waited okay yeah and teenagers
that's 10 years that's like a long time
we didn't have sex together straight
away and first did it only a few weeks
ago I was a virgin before that so I'm
not experienced at all so far I've not
been able to make her come
still
before dating me my girlfriend was
dating my brother oh
okay yikes
they're also 17. I don't like serious
for their relationships you know if
she's so sexually active that's true she
may not she may have been a virgin too I
don't know no he didn't mention that
okay true
you and your brother yeah right Jesus
Christ she's got porn achievement
unlocked man
um
before dating me my girlfriend was
dating my brother it was so awkward at
first but we're all okay now oh no I
mean I just still can't get away I hate
it I hate it that's weird I really hate
it you know in high school there was
this um I dated this one guy for like a
really short time but it wasn't like the
way we started dating was like in a
drunken party situation where he kind of
like just pushed himself on me and I'm
like okay fine
but his brother was so hot and I'm like
[ __ ] it was his younger brother and
I'm like God I wish I was with his
younger brother even later his younger
brother was kind of hitting on me after
like we stopped dating because it was
like literally like a very short time
and I was like no I I just can't I
cannot even though I really want you
achievement she didn't make out with him
no I couldn't if I could let you get
away with that no I couldn't like I
literally couldn't but he's like no fun
he was so fine yeah that's rough like
when when you meet the brother and
you're like holy [ __ ] no I had always
liked the brother okay I had always like
the younger brother but then the older
one like really pushed himself on me
during that party
and at that party
my friend that I was with ended up being
with the younger brother and she didn't
even care about him or like him or
nothing and I'm like God we should have
switched yeah that's rough it's a great
feeling when you can't meet your
boyfriend's siblings and friends and
you're like you realize you got the
hottest one yes
so [ __ ] up
human but it's [ __ ] up
anyways okay so it was awkward at first
but we're all okay now anyways so last
night I tried my best to make her come
but in the end she told me to quote just
stop so I did then she said quote
then she said quote your brother turned
me on so much more than you do oh this
girl is a [ __ ]
I knew this [ __ ] was Troubled Waters and
he better get the [ __ ] out of there
why would you say that why would you be
[ __ ] a girl that your brother dated
that's first of all why are you in this
situation yeah that too you did this to
yourself my God that's so cool she's a
[ __ ] though she is a [ __ ] absolute
[ __ ] wow I don't think it's there's
probably no circumstance where it's okay
to be like so and so was better than you
yeah like why would you ever need to say
that to anyone yes like what justifies
that that's crazy
bad breakup I guess if they're saying
[ __ ] up [ __ ] to you yeah then I can
see it coming out but like unless they
did something if they didn't do anything
to you why would you [ __ ] hit that
hard that's crazy
it's just a game for her probably yeah
they're young actually psycho actually I
bet you she was head over heels for the
brother she's trying to get him back yes
Yeah by using the little brother
maybe she's been playing the long game
yeah because they weren't even she was
probably just
not really she's like you break my heart
I'm taking your brother's virginity
that's cold
I don't like her I mean if that's what
she's doing like if the older brother
the other brother like cheated on her or
something yeah and like treat her like
she can't use someone I know you can't
morally it's wrong but damn so messed up
that's genius but that's [ __ ] up but
damn that's genius no Gina no I know
down girl down girl get down like she's
making women look bad
um not a fan uh let's see uh let me see
I was so shocked by her saying that I
didn't know what to say back she got
dressed and left the house and we
haven't spoken yet I just feel so
confused about how I feel I know I'm not
as attractive as my brother oh
look at that am I just being
upset over nothing no that's [ __ ] up
no I understand she's probably fed up
and she might have just said it in the
moment no no this is not okay in any
circumstance in any way whatsoever it's
not your fault there's nothing wrong
with you oh god wow this poor thing this
is gonna traumatize some problem yeah
he's gonna turn it to an Andrew Tate
yeah I'm gonna bring him up in every
episode by the way I know I've noticed
oh my God like I literally know like
two things about this man I've heard way
too I've watched way too many videos
about it um let's see top comment is I
guess your brother was the one that
broke up with her she's not working for
you man she's with you for your brother
if she liked you she would teach you
leave her yeah hold your brother uh he's
17 as well we're twins not identical
though oh she sets you up bro this
relationship was doomed from the
beginning
someone that your sibling has dated yeah
don't that's weird unless it was for
like a day and then you're like kids and
then like years later yeah like there
could be like there was never really
anything there type of situation but
like don't just don't oh my God also
nobody's great in sex in the beginning
it takes practice yeah don't worry
that's not your fault oh my god
um uh mom here not your mom but I'm a
mom
[Music]
in case you aren't getting what people
are telling you she's dating you because
of your brother you're either a stand-in
or Revenge dump her also no matter what
anyone says sex takes time and
experience to be great nobody knows that
what they're doing in the beginning in
her case she's better because she's
selfish so even the fireworks weren't
there they never would be with this girl
yeah oh my god
um one don't date any of your brothers
or friends exes never two it seems
pretty obvious she's dating you to stay
close to your brother yeah quote just in
case or as Revenge yeah
um yeah that whole man that sucks and
then also this one says you're smashing
your bro's ex you kind of set yourself
up for that one bro yeah yeah that is
yeah that's weird I hate to his twin
brother too but I think he learned his
lessons yeah it's a [ __ ] that's a
long con this [ __ ] was dedicated eight
months yeah holy [ __ ]
how bad did he [ __ ] you up girl what
happened Jesus he definitely left
something in her soul something dark
sometimes teenagers are crazy hell yeah
I 28 male got beat up in front of my
girlfriend she's 29 female
it was late and we were Rising it was
late and we were walking about the about
in the park I went to the restroom I
come back and some jack off is sexually
harassing my girlfriend she's very
uncomfortable doing her best not to
panic and lets him know uh and that her
boyfriend is nearby he's not listening I
approach him and kindly tell him to [ __ ]
off or I'll call the police dude is very
clearly drunk and I can smell the beer
on him as we turn and leave he grabs her
ass and tells her to leave me and come
with him I turn around I hit him my
girlfriend's been a victim of sexual
assault before and she's doing her best
not to break down I'll spare you the
details other than I got my ass kicked
he left after that my girlfriend had a
panic attack in the car after that I
just feel like I'm a letdown that I
couldn't help her I feel embarrassed
emasculated she's been a victim of
sexual assault before so this harassment
is traumatic and I wasn't able to help
her I wasn't there for her I feel
worthless I could have held it in I
could have left earlier like she wanted
it's been two days and she still
traumatized over it she has an emergency
therapy meeting today and hasn't been to
work she's been crying and I've
attempted to help her but I can't it's
clear that I can't what do I do that's
sad
I feel like okay so you got beat up but
that look not everyone's
once there man yeah like your intentions
were there to protect her and to try to
save her yeah and things could have
gotten worse if you weren't there and
you tried
honestly that's like also like if one of
us were there it's the same level of
like protection and also non-protection
like because basically now every time
something scary happens she's gonna look
at her boyfriend and be like oh he's
just gonna get his ass kicked so we
better like it's like I have my
girlfriend here with me yeah like I
don't even I have nothing that's [ __ ]
rough like you start taking some
fighting classes or something I don't
know if that makes him insecure yeah
take some fighting classes or whatever
makes her feel insecure too yeah also at
the same time like don't be so hard on
yourself the fact that you even stepped
up knowing that you can't fight yeah
that's a lot of balls to do that and
it's masculine yeah exactly that's more
masculine than running away exactly yeah
um protecting her isn't just physically
protecting her you're there trying to
help her through it too you know keeping
her well she's totally alone it would
obviously have been worse because like
him getting his ass beat was at least
the protecting her he got her out of
this situation because like he was now
the prey I guess yeah so
like if that's so rough if a guy stepped
in to defend my honor and try to fight
and still got beat up I'd be like dude
at least he stepped up right instead of
like I've dated [ __ ] before where I
had to fight you know I mean yeah I
wouldn't have any like I would feel good
that he was there I just don't know how
he's gonna recover from letting himself
down like that's he's gonna need therapy
I think or he can work towards it take
fighting classes and work out you know
if that's what it made you feel then
take the steps yeah right steps towards
it to make yourself feel better yeah I
feel bad for him though because he's
like I just I wanted to help and I made
it worse
your intentions were there I mean just
the way like if we want to like admit
that the patriarchy still exists like
that is so deeply ingrained in him that
that's gonna probably be traumatizing
for him now like he's probably
traumatized now yeah for sure so that's
really [ __ ] then again they just say
that the guy that I dated was a [ __ ]
for not knowing how to fight well now
more for like I had to do the fights
right like that's more of a [ __ ] did
you have to fight though or were you
just being popping off for no reason oh
no you physically had to fight to get
out of the situation not necessarily
physically but stepped up to defend his
honor in any way even you defended his
honor yeah okay yeah what were they
doing
um they were constantly for years it was
the one that I told you like I went to
like we went to their wedding and I told
the bride I would beat the [ __ ] out of
her oh yeah I remember that yeah I
remember the story because she was an
absolute raging c word and I never use
that word yeah yeah yeah she's awful she
beats her husband and [ __ ]
um
so top comment is what if you hadn't
been there that guy is definitely a
scumbag but I'm glad you were there even
if you got beat up because he most
likely would have done a lot worse yeah
to her the event definitely brought back
horrible memories for her and I'm so
happy she's in therapy my advice is just
be there for her emotionally support her
as well you saved her that night not be
there for her now right getting your ass
kicked is still supporting your
girlfriend whether you kicked his ass or
got your ass kicked the situation would
have been the same trauma for her you're
dealing with your own trauma of getting
your ass kicked and not feeling secure
enough in your manhood dealing with it
yourself first get over that then be
ready to support your girlfriend the way
she needs it nothing you would have done
that day would have changed the way she
felt Until you realize this you'll be
stuck in the same endless cycle
yeah I feel bad for them both yeah also
drunk guys have Incredible strength yeah
yeah there's a reason why my Hospital's
ER make sure all the drunks are escorted
by security and restraints are nearby
they can't feel pain they're like no oh
yeah you know what I mean like so it's
not really a fair fight yes maybe I'll
fill it till later maybe it's a good
idea to take a self-defense class with
your girlfriend I found that that helped
my self-esteem and confidence a lot even
when I don't technically have to defend
myself don't blame yourself you did
everything you could yeah I don't know
where I heard this the other day but I
was listening to something and they were
like self-defense classes are pointless
it gives people like confidence when
they actually like it's useless like
shitty kind of um I heard that too and
I'm like I don't know know like hey a
little curious
paper spray something like just like
have like something else with you if
you're going to be in situations like
that maybe since you know you can't
fight right
um maybe just have like another
deterrent or figure out like be more
self-aware of like
where you're at what time it is who else
is around you like don't go down like
streets yeah like try to be a little bit
more self-aware of the street smarts
type of things and like don't like bring
your girlfriend to some bar that's gonna
close at three and then you have to walk
down this crazy alley you know like just
maybe make different choices of how you
go out I don't know but also it's just
like there's Predators everywhere and
you can't you know yeah you can't really
avoid it
all right next one boyfriend won't stop
telling me that I have Bo okay all right
let's get into this here all right maybe
she does have Bo and yes it's like a
problem man sure you know so she so she
hears it the first time she does nothing
does she not yeah
like if people like maybe one of you she
eats like maybe something that she eats
it just smells oh yeah maybe she's one
of those girls that takes a whole bunch
of uh
fennel or whatever like flaxseed or
something I don't know there's some
something some supplement that makes
yeah that makes your your Bo like really
some diets too like or like certain
people's chemistry just reacts with
their diets more to make them smell more
yeah but like what if she doesn't shower
fenugreeks is what I was trying to say
anyway deodorant what if she's like one
of those people now that's like all
natural and I don't use deodorant and
blah blah blah and don't shower hippies
what if she's a dirty [ __ ] hippie
[Music]
it's a new life change now well then
break up how could you see that's the
that's weird to me that they're even
together because smell is such a big
deal when people are like courting and
dating yeah whatever like pheromones are
so strong like I don't know how unless
he was just like god this chick stinks
but I have no other options you know and
he was like gagging his way through
their whole like I wouldn't be able to
courtship yeah yeah I couldn't I
couldn't do it either and I couldn't be
that person where like if someone tells
me that I smell once
I'm dumping myself in perfume or
something or like that could be whatever
soap under my armpits forever you could
also maybe just like see a doctor and be
like is this do you think is this diet
or is something wrong with me like why
am I yeah so like terribly smelly right
because I have that rule if you can
smell yourself a little then everyone
can tell you a lot yeah so like if
someone told me that I would make sure
they would never have to tell me again
or no one would all right so I've been
with my boyfriend for over a year and
everything has been great except for one
thing every single day at least once
every single day you will tell me that I
stink and smell of Bo
when we met I showered every day applied
regular deodorant in the morning brush
my teeth three times a day oh okay well
calm down three times a day who are you
trying to impress dating a dentist Jesus
now I'm so paranoid about smelling bad
that I shower at least twice a day I
apply I apply a new industrial strength
deodorant every few hours I have a
reminder on my phone Jesus perfume and I
brush my teeth anytime I drink or eat
something that isn't water I feel like
I'm going crazy I didn't think I smelled
bad in the beginning I don't think I
smell bad now but I obviously smell bad
to him is she asking someone else like
do I smell that or is this guy [ __ ]
crazy yeah you like doing some weird
mind control [ __ ] yeah because maybe
they're related or something oh yeah
[Music]
because you're yeah I feel like you're a
chemistry makes you like gag to things
that are too close to your like you need
diverse jeans so if your jeans are too
close then exactly you're supposed to
like gag to them yeah what you're stinky
you're too much like me I'm not weirdly
keeps sneakily smelling their own
armpits that's not weird we do it all
the time yeah like make sure we're okay
it smells like degree yeah same I wear a
dove
um I've been to a doctor and he has said
there's nothing metal wrong medically
wrong it has honestly gotten to the
point where I literally shoved my armpit
in my friends and Family's faces [ __ ]
this guy asking if I smell bad and they
all say I don't smell like Bo at all one
friend even said I smelled too clean
like a Lush store wow I'm getting so
paranoid he won't cuddle or anything
when he says I smell I really don't know
yeah he's cheating or they're related
he's cheating or he doesn't actually
like her and so he's like making excuses
she's a kisser and hug her and [ __ ] like
that do you think it's a medical issue
he's having like he smells things weird
you know like the kobit nose like yeah
because like now I don't know if this is
TMI but like when I take a [ __ ] it
doesn't smell like [ __ ] anymore oh yeah
it smells like organic it smells like
some organic byproduct that I can't
describe but my [ __ ] doesn't smell like
[ __ ] anymore so my nose is permanently
like change so maybe he has covered
knows and he's just smelling something
that we can't I would ask him like does
anyone else smell bad to you or is it
just right oh and you know what else
change the smell of my dogs so you know
dogs have that kind of like Frito smell
usually kind of and like there's a
little bit of a like wet dog smell it's
kind of gross but then like dry dog
smell kind of sometimes is kind of just
smells like fur like Fritos like my dogs
now smell to me like butter Oh weird no
not cute it smells like butter like
greasy butter I love butter but not like
but like day old butter like not
buttered butter I've never smelled
butter out of it butter that's not good
anymore like butter that's kind of
turning anyways
like musty you know like I don't know
musty old butter anyways so what I'm
saying is my dogs who I used to shove my
face into
smell their paws that like I would just
smell their [ __ ] paws like that now
they just smell now I'm like oh God you
stink weird all right do you think
no it happened after coven
um okay
um oh there's an update update I waited
for him to make a comment this morning
so I can talk to him it was less than an
hour after waking up that he said God
you stink [ __ ] first of all just stop
saying it every [ __ ] day even if it's
true
it's so rude yeah or just stop [ __ ]
saying it like my girlfriend stinks I'm
just gonna eat it I'm just gonna deal
with it yeah she's a stinky gal
she's a stinky cat right I had already
showered and put on deodorant I snapped
and I asked him what exactly was he
smelling because at this point I'm one
of the cleanest people on the planet
yeah and if I still smell bad to him
then we should just break up absolutely
yeah because nothing's fixing it
apparently he got all panicked and upset
I eventually got out of him that this is
what his what his father always did to
his mother apparently his father told
him that Megan it was just like some
controlling apparently his goddamn
people grammar spelling please Jesus
people podcasts are trying to read your
posts they're trying to steal your
content seriously apparently his father
told him that this was a Surefire
technique to have a woman never leave
you because she will quote she will feel
too low to cheat will love only you and
will always be clean that makes me feels
so horrible she needs to break up with
him immediately
and that poor guy to get such horrible
advice from a father he's [ __ ] stupid
oh my God he neither but as a child
knowing that like growing up you're a
man you're an adult now yes no excuses
excuse for a thousand I agree for sure
but sometimes things are embedded in you
that you're just like wait that's wrong
needless to say his father is wrong he's
packing his things he's moving out of my
house today thank you yeah
wow that's is he tortured her crazy
[ __ ] year basically yeah stinky
smelly pieces
basically all the money spent on soaps
deodorants doctors appointments yeah no
that's wow so why did she deal with this
one yeah first of all people will treat
you how you let them so that was so you
waited way too [ __ ] long I hope you
learned your lesson don't do that [ __ ]
again how common says holy [ __ ] that
update his father basically groomed him
to be an emotional abuser yeah so long
you ended that and hopefully he learns
from this wow oh my goodness that is
that's annoying that's so [ __ ]
annoying imagine telling a girl she
smells to make her want you more [ __ ]
people are stupid I feel bad for that
guy's mom Yeah that poor woman and the
lot like the way his dad says it makes
them insecure but also it makes sure
that they're always clean that's so
[ __ ] creepy it's disgusting that's so
disgusting it's really disgusting
because like women are typically usually
pretty like self-aware and hygiene yeah
most of the time yeah like more so than
guys I would say yes
how clean do they need to be like what
the [ __ ] he's nagging you so that you're
desperate to earn his approval break up
with this piece of [ __ ] he's utterly
pathetic and manipulative how disgusting
damn dude wow that's crazy people in the
world are [ __ ] crazy yeah these
stories and their twists what the [ __ ]
the sister with the tattoo yeah I'm
still gasping at that wow that's crazy
we're so juicy so juicy my God I love it
down lots of people's problems are great
other people's problems are amazing what
a break from our lives
if you enjoyed that hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for watching let
you let us know what you guys think in
the comments because holy [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] was that
um and we will see you guys next time
check out our sponsors like us subscribe
to subscribe to us follow us on social
medias okay love you bye you smell [ __ ]
go take a shower no nagging
[Music]